[Música]
y hablamos de economía en directo
américa de france 24 ya está conmigo en
el estudio daniela blandón danny
bienvenida ya pues avanzamos en un día
más de directo américa y vamos a iniciar
esta sección económica con las
consecuencias inmediatas de este acuerdo
sobre las nuevas sanciones de la unión
europea a rusia no hola raúl muy buenos
días para los líderes de la unión
europea sin que en este martes reunidos
en bruselas para discutir más a fondo
sobre seguridad y energía después de
haber llegado a un acuerdo para vetar
parcialmente el petróleo ruso como parte
esto de un sexto paquete de sanciones
contra moscú el embargo una vez impuesto
legalmente en los próximos días afectará
a los envíos marítimos de petróleo ruso
y abarcará la mayoría de las
importaciones de rusia
una vez que polonia y alemania deje de
comprarlo a finales del 2022 un 10 por
ciento de los envíos de petróleo estará
sin embargo temporalmente exento para
que los países sin salida al mar como
hungría eslovaquia y república checa-
pues hagan acceso a través de los
oleoductos me tiene triste ariella se
leyó a liberar mi nombre
nos vemos todos los días lo que pasa
para los demás danny el impacto que he
tenido este anuncio en el mercado así
como cuando usted dice vamos con
deportes
pues mire aunque al paquete todavía le
hacen falta aprobaciones finales al
menos ya hay un principio de acuerdo y
eso ha hecho que por un lado los precios
del petróleo estén cotizando fuertemente
al alza con el brent del mar del norte
subiendo alrededor del 2 por ciento a
casi 124 dólares por barril llegando a
casi a precios de marzo de este año y el
w y del golfo de méjico rozando los 120
dólares el mercado ruso también
reaccionó el rublo revirtió las pérdidas
y se cotizaba al cierre de la jornada en
cerca de 61 rublos por cada dólar un 16
por ciento más que el lunes y las
acciones europeas por su parte tocaron
mínimos de sesión este martes además de
esta noticia por los datos de inflación
de los que vamos a hablar así es habla
de inflación entonces le preguntó cuál
entonces fueron estos datos de inversión
recién revelados bueno el aumento de los
precios en los 19 países de la eurozona
tocó un nuevo máximo histórico en mayo
hasta el 8,1
según una primera estimación los más
afectados son los vecinos de rusia
polonia y belarús hablamos de estonia
lituania y letonia cuyos precios en
comparación con los del año pasado han
crecido hasta en un 20% en mayo mientras
que la inflación se ha estabilizado en
malta francia y finlandia por debajo del
7,1 por ciento
este resultado grupal estuvo impulsado
desde luego por los precios de la
energía que está en un 40% más altos que
el año pasado bueno y la gran ucrania
afecta especialmente a un producto muy
tradicional en italia le gusta mucho
cual esa pasta hagamos la pasta por
favor señor pues mire antes de la
invasión rusia y ucrania proveían
conjuntamente una tercera parte del
trigo mundial que ahora está bloqueado
con otros cereales porque los puertos
del mar negro y del mar de azov están
cerrados en italia entonces el impacto
ya lo sienten los agricultores los
importadores los consumidores en
especial de este delicioso alimento
nuestra corresponsal en italia natalia
mendoza nos cuenta más
desde hace más de 50 años la familia de
domenico carone cultiva trigo en este
terreno de 70 hectáreas en apulia la
principal región italiana productora de
cereales un cultivo cuyos costos se han
disparado desde el inicio de la guerra
en ucrania el costo de fertilizante el
precio de los fertilizantes se ha
triplicado porque la mayor parte de los
fertilizantes que usamos aquí en italia
viene de los países en guerra conflicto
esta mañana con un sindicato agrícola
domenico analiza un posible aumento de
su superficie de cultivo con horno
juniors lo que la región quiere cultivar
cien mil hectáreas suplementarias de
trigo para prevenir la escasez de
cereales debido al bloqueo de las
importaciones de rusia y ucrania si
producimos más trigo aquí en italia
podríamos liberarnos de la dependencia
de otros países hay que cultivar más
aquí se trata de una estrategia nacional
que busca la autosuficiencia y la
soberanía alimentaria soberanía
alimentaria un objetivo ambicioso
actualmente y tal importa más del 30 por
ciento del trigo que consume en forma de
pan galletas
el plato nacional los productores de
pasta que usan trigo italiano también se
ven afectados como esta empresa familiar
de pasta artesanal como ya no llevan
cereales de ucrania los productores que
usaban esas harinas ahora todos buscan
harinas italianas y el mercado interno
no da abasto para cubrir toda esta
demanda
haciendo una venta al detalle nos vemos
obligados a trasladar parte de los
aumentos en el precio final al
consumidor y paralelamente reducir
nuestros márgenes de ganancia el
gobierno espera en los próximos meses
aumentar las importaciones de cereales
de países como canadá o grecia para
evitar que estalle una crisis
alimentaria en italia y por favor que
nunca se acabe la pasta larga y de la
pasta danny cifra el día cifra el día de
raúl 77 por ciento este es el desempleo
en abril en en el trimestre comprendido
entre febrero y abril de este año en
chile baja 25 puntos porcentuales frente
al mismo período del año pasado comienza
ya a ceder el desempleo en este país
bueno una cifra positiva
esta cifra también pues se copia y se
replique en todos los países de américa
latina por favor si por favor daniela
gracias entonces portal de información
nos vemos mañana no en la próxima hora
ya que vas a ser la única de hoy ya esté
desconcentrado es daniela